وفي تطورات مدنيه اخرى قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان طيرانها شن خلال ساعات
الماضيه 24 ضربه على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه وانظمتها الصاروخيه وان قواتها
اسقطت ثلاثه مسيرات روسيه واصابت مركزا
للسيطره وخمسه مناطق لتمركز الافراد
والاعتاد الروسي ومستودعين للذخيره وفي
مدينه مليليه قال عمده المدينه الاوكرانيه
انفجارات دوت في المدينه التي تسيطر عليها
القوه الروسيه نتيجه قصف اوكرانيا استاذه
قاعده عسكريه للقوه الروسيه هناك اما
حاكمه مقاطعه دنيتك الاوكراني فقال ان
قصفا بالصواريخ سادف مدن اكرامي تورس
وبخمود وكان الجيش الاوكراني اكد سابقا
استمرار سيطرته على مدينه ضخمه وفي
العاصمه كياد ذكر قائد القوات هناك خلال
حديث الى وكاله المحليه ان منطقه كييف
مستعده لاي هجوم محتمل ويوجد وحولها عده
خطوط دفاعا يبلغ طولها الاجمالي نحو 1,000
كلم